At church on Sunday,
we started talking about how we can be better neighbors to each other.
And someone chimed in and said that whenever she's sick,
she knows that her one neighbor
is gonna bring over her famous cabbage soup.
And I just love that.
First of all,
I love the idea of being known for your famous cabbage soup.
And I also love that this neighbour was taking over her soup
to anyone that was sick around her.
So when I got home, I knew what we were gonna have for.
For lunch. It was gonna be cabbage soup.
So we went to the garden, we yanked out all of our cabbages,
we clean them, we sliced them.
We also sliced up some shallots and garlic and diced those.
And then we needed a protein,
so we added our ground pork in a bowl with tons of spices and herbs,
and we made a ground pork meatball.
We cook those up, and then we sauteed our shallots and garlic.
We added some bone broth. Then we threw in all our cabbage.
I also used our paprika, Rosemary,
French salt blend in the soup,
and it was the perfect spice.
It was so good.
And then we threw in the meatballs at the end and let it simmer,
and it turned out amazing.
We had it for lunch, we had it for dinner.
To serve, I put some sharp cheese and a hefty squeeze of lemon
and some fresh Thyme. Which
I feel like the lemon just brightened the whole soup up
and made it so good.
And I just want you all to know that I'm on my way
to perfecting my famous cabbage soup recipe.